8 tiro internati sono i dottori in
questo nuovo video siri e che
collegheranno il mio live quindi
sceglieranno come vado a fare lo slime
ora vi faccio vedere come fine video
dovreste votare se vi è piaciuto di più
lo stress senza tasti o lo slime scelto
da google
lasciate un bel laica questo video e se
volete vedere altri video già al 3 mesi
in cui si ri e google controllare le
cose magari il prossimo la passò in cui
interesse sceglie il mio slime fatemi
sapere nei commenti se vi potrebbe
interessare oppure scrivetemi le vostre
idee nei commenti e ora iniziamo subito
iniziamo con siri speriamo che si
comporti bene
sapete che l'altra volta sei comportata
vale il fili e non mi voleva rispondere
non mi voleva ad arber risposto e poi vi
lascio alla fine di questo video il link
a quel video è stato tutto molto bisogna
cercare di lime con scritte le iniziali
del proprio nome quindi nel mio caso a
sé voglio mettere il mio cognome di
altrimenti a s quindi proviamo stiamo in
google che con si ricerche immagini
slime ma come jack e immagini slim e ha
l ok in questo caso fini non getta con a
f
quindi le chiederemo semplicemente di
cercare immagini tease live prenderemo
la prima immagine che si propone cerchi
mani libere apriamo
e sapete qual è il primo è un fly drive
maledizione la mia maledizione proprio
vabbè facciamo queste strade hitler
berne è qui chiediamo google ricercare
lo slime con le mie iniziali e speriamo
di trovare qualcosa di più carino ok
iniziamo con l'alcol bianca devo anche
cercare di farlo delle stesse dimensioni
il che sarà molto difficile poi dopo
darete un voto in base a quanto è simile
alla foto schiuma da barba
ho messo anche un pochettino di gel da
barba
ok ora aggiungo il verde maledizione
questo qua con online un matto per
vestire uguale vediamo questo forse un
po più scuro allora vado a prendere un
altro verde
eccolo qua ma dimmi tu veramente la
maledizione del verde allora ad un
gruppo di lozione così diventa ancora
più morbido e ora aggiungo il firth e
non era molto scuro e il verde quindi
questi dovrebbe bastare vediamo
riguardo la foto così bello se steste
famiglia
città e che manifestiamo magari giù
un'altra goccia perché è abbastanza
chiaro con verde
ok direi che come colore ci stiamo ora
andiamo ad attivarlo e vediamo se esse
della stessa consistenza speriamo che la
soluzione per lenti e la polvere di
unicorno
ok ragazzi ci siamo in quanto è quasi
pronto però cristiano scelto uguale
sarete poi a deciderlo con i vostri
volti mi raccomando dovete essere onesti
di allora che un po è ancora un pochino
pc coso questa cosa non mi piace proprio
ho preso ho cambiato collo ho preso la
scuola mi sembra che si chiamò scholar
ed è molto più liquida e in parte ci
vuole molto più tempo ad attivarlo
però una cosa positiva è che rimane un
po più blues in vedete però preferivo
l'altra
[Applauso]
esiste che strano rimane molto liquido
però sembra quasi glossy slime
[Applauso]
ok ragazze ci siamo e suri mi piace un
sacco
ora devo provare a riprodurre la foto
esattamente come l'abbiamo vista allora
a rivedere che vendiamo
forse era un pochino più grande è quello
della foto
ecco che cosa ne pensate ragazzi date un
voto per somiglianza da 1 a 10
e questo è il primo onlive scelto da
siri possiamo ora allo slide scelto da
google
allora scommettiamo che anche il
quattrocento da google sarà verde
scrivetelo nei commenti secondo quelli
che colore sarà vediamo chi indovina
come vi dicevo prima basta scrivere le
vostre iniziali del nostro nome e
cognome e poi scrivere lime il primo che
capita e quello che bisogna riprodurre
andiamo con le mie iniziali a di lime
[Musica]
guardate il primo slime è lo strato
trasparente che purtroppo non si può
fare subito perché bisogna aspettare ora
troviamo con le mie iniziali anita
stories
guardate un po c'è uno slam a tema la
bella e la bestia
io allora la bella e la bestia in
pratica il giallo dorato con tantissimi
glitter e le rose dentro wow
allora posso provare a fare questo però
non ho nessuna rosa rossa quindi
utilizzerò qualcos'altro al posto delle
rose che iniziano con la colla
trasparente
ecco fatto poi metto una goccia di
giallo non troppo un paio di gocce
mescoliamo che ora è un giallo chiaro
ora dobbiamo aggiungere un bel po di
glitter dorati che giungono via primo
boccetta di peli per doroti autori kit
il chiamo le vediamo che effetto fa ma
che bello
giustizia un sacco ad aggiungere
un'altra concetta ha ora vado ad
attivarlo poi a cinque le altre
decorazioni non so bene cosa aggiungere
al posto delle rose
allora come alternativa con un po di
diamantini che fanno un bell'effetto e
mettere in fiches ball magari solo
quelli rossi così si assomiglia di più
oppure queste conchigliette rosse
scrivetemi nei commenti secondo voi
quale si sta meglio che i ragazzi non
sono quasi pronto quasi attivato del
tutto alla fine ho deciso di mettere
queste rosse perché sono belle piste
miglianti anche gli altri pezzi si
sarebbero stati bene ma sono meno
somiglianti
ecco qua purtroppo è ma solo questi
rossi ora andiamo a mischiarlo ok
ragazzi questo è lo slime scelto da
google pare vediamo l'ora con la foto
ecco qua allora la differenza è che
ancora festa non si è schiarito
purtroppo a tutte le bollicine e più non
onerose purtroppo però fatemi sapere se
vi piace comunque questo slime io adoro
i suoni che vi parla alla ragazzi quale
club mi è piaciuto di più questo cesso
da google della bella e la bestia o
questo scelto da siri verde map la foto
scrivete vini cometti chi vinse google o
tiri a me per aspetto piace che in
quello di google ma persone mi piace di
più questo di sì
scrivetemi di comete se volete vedere
l'ha stracciata ingestibile e ora ve
l'assicuro 4 quadratini
come potete cliccare o il plesso
scappando sono scappate per vedere i
prossimi video le mie altre challenge i
miei altri slime cliccare su quello che
preferite e buona visione